yippee-ki-yay movie lovers its Chan here
and today I'm breaking down the amazing
New Avengers infinity war trailer for
Marvel Easter eggs and other cool
details you might have missed if you
hear for the first time I do regular
Marvel videos and to celebrate the new
trailer I'm kicking off a new round of
my infinity war giveaway for all my
subscribers just leave me a comment
below about the new trailer or any
requests you have for infinity war
videos obviously speculation and
potential spoilers ahead for infinity
war the new trailer introduces more
backstory for Thanos with Gamora
revealing her father's chilling mission
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one ball to wipe out half the
universe if he gets all the Infinity
stones she can do it with the snap of
his fingers just like that and that snap
is a reference to the classic Infinity
Gauntlet storyline where Thanos
literally snaps his fingers when he's
wearing the gauntlet and half of the
universe disappears this is an awesome
Easter Egg although we might not
actually get Thanos's exact snap moment
in the movie for example we may see the
Mad Titans fingers about to perform that
move followed by a sudden cut to black
similar to how at the end of Avengers
age of Ultron the camera cut before cap
finished the famous comic book
catchphrase Avengers Assemble
vengers Dallas's voice-over is as
chilling as his mission and proves that
his view of balancing the universe is a
twisted li+ one the end is near when I'm
done half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced as all things should
be
notice how the nose is a glass half-full
guy he's pointing out how half of
humanity will still exist in perfect
balance before Stannis will need the
time Stern and we get a terrifying shot
of ebony more torturing dr. strange and
it instantly brought to mind this scene
from the comics who are evany more
manipulates dr. strange into becoming an
unwitting pawn for Thanos M&E more has
the ability to deceive even the
strongest of minds and I think we're
going to see dr. strange used by more in
some kind of deception against the
Avengers or get some pretty incredible
scenes in the new trailer we see him
with rocket and Groot on the Dwarven
planet need Evalia
where he's gone in search of a new
weapon now that he no longer has his
hammer Mjolnir and we get to see an
awesome scene where a cape-wearing Thor
powers up and harnesses either his own
lightning powers all the powers of
something else perhaps an infinity stone
to create his new weapon it's not shown
in the trailer but various tie-in toys
have confirmed that the new weapon will
be Stormbreaker and the handle looks to
be made from wood that group donates
from his own body Stormbreaker is an axe
like hammer which in the comics was
originally wielded by beta ray bill
bills a popular comic book character who
after proving himself worthy enough to
wield Thor's normally unlivable hammer
was given the new hammer Stormbreaker by
Odin and like mule near bills hammer was
created by the dwarves of NIDA valium in
the comics Stormbreaker had the same
powers as Thor's mule near so it'll be
interesting to see how Thor uses it in
infinity war and if there are any
differences with his original hammer in
the previous trailer we saw the black
order attempt to extract the mind stone
from visions forehead and as I predicted
then the Avengers have taken vision to a
candor to try and safely remove it in
this shot work and in high tech genius
Sheree is using her kimono beads to
project an image of vision you can see
down at the bottom of the screen she
looks to be showing this image to Bruce
Banner whose glasses you can see flash
by just to the side of the shot sure he
seems to be working out or actually even
showing banner how she can extract the
mind stone from vision while keeping him
alive we know from the Avengers infinity
war prelude comic and the Black Panther
post-credits scene that Sheree has
developed tech and Wakanda that removed
the Hydra programming from Bucky's brain
so it's not surprising that the Avengers
would call on her again for her
brilliance at inventing and using
cutting-edge tech this time to try to
help vision as was hinted at in the
first trailer Bruce Bannon will be
getting into Tony's Hulkbuster armor and
I really liked this shot of the Hulk
Buster standing tall and Falcon and war
machine flying past behind him but later
it looks like the Hulk Buster might not
be strong enough to withstand the
outrider attack as we see him getting
overwhelmed if you're worried about
Bruce banners chances of survival well I
think he's probably going to get out of
this one because a recent toy shows
Bruce Banner hulking out while inside
the Hulk Buster also the first trailer
showed a Hulk without any armor fighting
on the wakandan battlefield hopefully an
angry Hulk will be able to take out the
outrider swarming all over him at this
point this flashback shows Thanos and
his army conquering gamora's people with
the mad Titan taking a young Gamora away
from her family to raise as his own
remember this in the guardians of the
galaxy movies we've seen how Gamora is
very much phalluses favorite which
really hurt nebula when they were
growing up together in a recent II W
interview Josh Brolin said that although
Thanos uses his adoptive daughter Gamora
as a tool for his own gain he does feel
affection for her and will see the
evolution of their relationship over the
course of the film in flashback scenes
like this one after all conquering other
places and races and taking away some of
their youngsters was all part of
Stannis's grand plan which will see snap
into place in infinity war the fact that
Gomorrah is thanasis favorite may well
mean that in his eyes her betrayal of
all he stands for is simply unbearable
this is one of the many reasons I
believe the mad Titan will sacrifice
Gamora by the end of infinity war and I
talk about all the clues pointing to her
demise in my new
finiti war death theory video okay let's
talk
Ironman we get to see a bit more of his
suit capabilities when his foot
thrusters convert into a supercharged
rocket booster as he zooms up to the
circle of death which we know from
previous promos has Spider Man on board
the machine heads out into space and we
later see it smash onto a reddish orange
brown colored planet and in the
background as a ton of wreckage this
planet or moon is Thanos his homeworld
Titan as well as flashback scenes with
Gamora were likely going to see
flashbacks to Thanos's earlier life on
Titan recently Kevin Feige explained
will learn the Titans population went
extinct because of things that Sanaa
thought he could help prevent but he was
not allowed to do anything about them
and after that mass extinction Thanos
vowed not to let it happen again now in
the background of the planet there are
various giant objects strewn around
which are likely left over from titans
destruction in fact I wonder whether
they might be parts of a giant machine
remembering guardians of the galaxy the
collector introduced us to the power of
the Infinity stones and we saw a
celestial destroying a whole planet it
might be that something similar happened
on Titan and Celestials attacked
Thanos's homeworld
recently the reso brothers said we
should prepare for a loss of crying in
the cinema when we watch Avengers
infinity war and Kevin Feige has also
said we will be getting real character
deaths and in this new trailer I think
we get the biggest hint that Iron Man
might actually die listen to son awesome
watch who it cuts back to I hope they
remember you Tony's looking pretty
beaten down by this point with his armor
broken and Thanos's words obviously echo
the fact that Iron Man kick-started the
whole of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I also think it's interesting that the
Marvel Studios intro logo was zoomed
right in on the are when it came on in
this trailer and right there bang in the
center of two pictures of Tony Stark a
subtle hint perhaps that he's at the
core of this movie we've also had all
the soulstone promo art teases with Iron
Man in the middle of the soulstone and
I'm getting a feeling that Marvel could
want infinity war to come full circle
back to the very first movie in the
franchise Iron Man Robert Downey jr. has
said that he wants to leave on a high
and going out in a blaze of glory in him
I see war would definitely fit that
ambition if Tony Stark really does die
I'm sure there will be a ton of misty
eyes in the theater now the editing in
the trailer could of course be a bit of
classic misdirection Dallas might be
saying this line to someone else for
example Spider Man who he saw getting
beaten down by Thanos in the first
trailer or perhaps to Thor or cap who we
also see that attack in the new trailer
by the way even if I'm man does die were
going to see Tony Stark again in
Avengers 4 as our DJ's been filming so
will either get flashback scenes or some
time travel shenanigans that the
remaining Avengers do to try to fix the
events of infinity war so if Iron Man
potentially dying wasn't enough for you
the trailer actually immediately cut to
Steve Rogers resisting Thanos and the
gauntlet first of all it's incredible
that cap is holding Thanos back with
just his hands and that reminds me of
how capped was the only one who managed
to make knio knio wobble a bit in Thor's
hammer lifting contest in age of Ultron
and also how cap held on to the winter
soldiers helicopter in Civil War as the
caps chances against the mad Titan well
he does have his new shields which are
bound to have some new capabilities
we've not yet seen however notice in
this shot that caps right arm is missing
its shield but in this latest shot the
shield is back this could mean simply
that these two shots in the trailer are
shown in a different order than they
appear in the final movie or it might
mean that caps arm shields are similar
to his triangular shield in the comics
in other words part of the shield is
used to protect himself while the other
part splits off to attack a body and I
talked in detail about caps new shield
in my video on that I am still worried
for cap though because in the Infinity
Gauntlet story when Steve Rogers went up
against Thanos the mad Titan easily
crushed Captain America shield and then
killed him like he was nothing I'm
hoping cap might hold out better here
but I wouldn't place a bet on his
chances of survival okay on a more
upbeat note I want to appreciate how
awesome this shot of Spidey swinging
through the floating wreckage of Titan
is it looks like this seen us in the
aftermath of when Thanos throws a moon
at the planet which was recently
released in a still and I imagine the
Avengers might have survived this attack
perhaps because Doctor Strange managed
to slow down time for himself
the other heroes as the moon landed on
the surface now I'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories on the new trailer
what's got you excited and who's got you
worried also leave me any requests or
questions you have about the trailer
which I'll follow up in another video
you can leave those in the comments or
tweet me at Jan underscore Gilbert or at
Flik city if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate you hitting that like button
and sharing the video the winner of my
last mod will giveaway is on screen now
if that's you send me a private message
with your details and I'll get your
prize out to you and if you want to
check out my infinity war death Theory
video or my other Marvel theory and
trailer breakdowns tap the screen right
here thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers